hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter 14 of
his work after virtue Alistair MacIntyre
is going to be starting out by posing a
question for us is there some sort of
unified account of the virtues that we
can come up with and part of what
McIntyre has been doing throughout the
entire work and really throughout his
career is looking at different ways in
which human beings historically have
understood and articulated and attempted
to practice and to teach or inculcate
the virtues and he tells us that there
are in fact different listings and
different understandings of the virtues
so it's not quite so simple as many of
the proponents of virtue ethics in a
very abstract way want to say where well
everybody recognizes there are these
basic virtues and everyone agrees on
them MacIntyre says that's not the case
at all he says if we think about and he
just brings up several different things
Homer Sophocles Aristotle the New
Testament and medieval thinkers differ
from each other in many ways he says
they offer different and here's where it
gets even more important incompatible
lists of the virtues they give a
different rank order of importance to
different virtues
and they have different and incompatible
theories of the virtues so they're not
all just simply using different language
to talk about the same thing MacIntyre
is saying there's a number of different
virtue ethics out there and we want to
understand which of them if any is
closer to the core of what we would call
a proper robust virtue ethics and then
he's going to discuss five different
let's call them Paragons of virtue
ethics exemplars that we can look at one
of these is Homer and we could sort of
shoehorn the Greek tragedians in there
as well another is Aristotle another is
found in the writings of the New
Testaments so for example the Gospels
and the various letters and then we have
Ben Franklin and Jane Austen you might
say well that's kind of a weird eclectic
list why would you possibly pick those I
mean I understand why you picked Homer
Aristotle and the New Testament cuz we
all know that those are great literature
why then Ben Franklin you know and why
of anybody Jane Austen who he doesn't
really talk that much about in this
chapter other than to give us a few sort
of hints about what what his view is he
says well each of these is
representative of a particular way of
understanding what the virtues would be
and how they ought to be ordered and
which ones matter the most and which
ones might actually be vices so as I
mentioned each has its own he says it
turns out the way in which these
catalogs are ordered in which items are
ranked is relatively central to human
experience and which it marginal these
are things that they disagree on and
there's also a relationship of virtues
to the social order so he gives examples
here for Homer the paradigm of human
excellence is who the warrior right
Agamemnon Achilles Odysseus to a certain
degree right and then he says for
Aristotle it's the Athenian gentleman
the cow can loci kethu is what it is in
Greek and he says indeed according to
Aristotle certain virtues are only
available to those of great riches and
high social status and then he says well
what about the the New Testament this
brings in some additional views and it's
different from Aristotle's point of view
he says that for the new testament not
only praises virtues of which aristotle
knows nothing faith hope and love the
theological virtues it says nothing
about virtues such as phronesis their
crucial for Aristotle and it praises one
quality as a virtue which Aristotle
seems to count as one of the vices
namely humility and it also has a
different view on the rich and whether
the virtues are available to people he
says then if we look at all three lists
of virtues considered so far the Homeric
the Aristotelian and the New Testament
if we compare them with two later lists
and here's where we get the the the
later thinkers one of which can be
compiled from Jane Austen's novels and
the other which Benjamin Franklin
constructed for himself so here's where
he does talk about Jane Austen he says
two features stand out in Jane Austen's
list the first is the importance
allotted to the virtue
she calls constancy so a different kind
of virtue being brought up here and
another is he says that what what
agreeableness viewed by Aristotle as a
good virtuous often translated as
friendliness right she says that this is
not actually a virtue this is just a
facsimile of a virtue so we already now
have a fourth point of view and then we
get Benjamin Franklin and with Benjamin
Franklin MacIntyre wants to stress we
get a very different conception of
virtue even though he's quite close to
Jane Austen in time
why is Franklin's listing of the virtues
so different he says we find almost all
the types of difference from at least
one of the catalogs we've considered and
one more Franklin includes virtues which
are new to our consideration what are
these cleanness or cleanliness silence
industry
he clearly considers the drive to
acquire itself part of virtue whereas
for the ancient Greeks this is the vise
of greed or play o nexia and then he
says he also redefines some familiar
virtues and what do we mean by
redefining well this is where we get to
different understandings of the virtues
Franklin if you've ever read his
autobiography where this is coming from
he provides a listing of these and each
of which is as McIntyre says elucidated
by citing a maxim obedience to which is
the virtue in question so on the one
hand
Franklin's treatment is we might say
more de ontological more rules focused
than is say Aristotle's or the New
Testament or Jane Austen which are in
some respect more traditionally virtue
ethics the way we typically understand
it on the other hand there's a different
measure and motive going on which
MacIntyre views as being quite frankly
utilitarian he says that Franklin's
account like Aristotle's account is
teleological that is the virtues are for
something they have a Telos and end a
goal for which the person who is
behaving virtuously is striving what is
that goal and how is it understood so he
tells us unlike Aristotle's Franklin's
account is utilitarian according to
Franklin in his autobiography the
virtues are means to an end but he
envisions envisages the means and
relationship as external rather than
internal we'll come back to that in just
moment the end to which cultivation the
virtues ministers is happiness but it's
happiness understood as success
prosperity in Philadelphia and
ultimately in heaven the virtues are to
be useful and Franklin's account
continuously stresses utility as a
criterion in individual cases so this is
a very different conception of the
virtues MacIntyre is going to tell us
that we can think of at least you know
three main conceptions of virtue here
which are really not entirely compatible
with each other and which we can find
outside of the narrow scope of just
Homer Aristotle New Testament Ben
Franklin and Jane Austen we can look at
other accounts of the virtues and say
they fit into this type they fit into
this type or they fit into this type and
when somebody's talking about virtue
ethics we probably want to figure out
which one they actually have in mind so
let's look at the first one which he
identifies with the Homeric paradigm in
this case what are virtues they are
qualities that allow a person to fulfill
a social role
the primary role being that of the
warrior what other people can have
virtue as well you know crewmate
companion can have the virtues
appropriate to that one's wife in the
case of Penelope can have the virtues
appropriate to that an old man like
Odysseus is father Laius can have the
virtues appropriate to him and we can go
on and on but each person by virtue of
the social role that they have needs
certain excellences that allow them to
discharge that role well and so
MacIntyre says that in this point of
view he says the concept of what anyone
feeling such and such a role ought to do
is prior to the concept of a virtue so
if we want to know on this account what
it means for a person to be virtuous we
need to know what sort of social role or
function they have and
we might think about this in our own
time let's say we get away from Homer
and we're looking at sort of the
American you know business workplace and
we think about what does it mean to be a
good person well it depends are you the
boss are you the employee are you an
employee on the factory floor
are you a truck driver moving things
from place to place are you perhaps in
HR for each of these it'll be a
different answer about what it means to
be virtuous different virtues will be
required for different roles and there
won't be any sort of unified conception
of human virtue as such because we're
focusing primarily just on our functions
a second possibility is offered by he
says Aristotle and the New Testament
both of them in their own way
and also to a certain extent Jane Austen
this views virtues as qualities that
enable an individual to move towards the
achievement of what MacIntyre calls a
specifically human Telos a specifically
human goal or end state and Aristotle
calls this happiness and the New
Testament also calls this happiness as
well as salvation and then you know in
this sort of account as he says even
though some virtues are available only
to certain types of people and
Aristotle's view virtues attach not to
people inhabit us
it's the Telos of human beings as a
species which determines what human
qualities are virtues this is what we
mean in talking about specifically human
Telos specifically not in the sense of
being very particular but in the sense
of being specific to the human race to
the kind of beings that we are so you
know if we take the business thing again
whether we're in HR whether we're in
sales whether we're in finance we all
need certain virtues
in order to be good human beings per se
in order to move towards what our Telos
or fulfillment would be now he says the
New Testament is also doing the same
thing and we should look at his
treatment of this very quickly he says
the New Testament account of the virtues
even if it differs an in content from
Aristotle has the same logical and
conceptual structure as Aristotle's
account a virtue is a quality the
exercise of which leads to the
achievement of the human fellows the
good for human beings is of course a
supernatural and not only a natural good
but Supernature redeems and completes
nature and he says the relationship of
virtues is means to an end which is
human incorporation in the divine
kingdom of the age to come is also
internal and not external just as it is
in aerosol so we should talk about that
a bit he says what does it mean for a
means to be internal to an end he says a
means is internal to it when the when
the end cannot be adequately
characterized independently of a
characterization of the means the two go
together what would be an example of
this well you tells us the exercise of
the virtues is itself part of the good
life crucial MacIntyre says to the good
life so this is a very different
conception of what virtues are then say
the homeric the role bound account when
we get to Ben Franklin and when we get
to other people like say the
utilitarians themselves Jeremy Bentham
perhaps to some degree
John Stuart Mill although MacIntyre sees
a possible redemption form to get into
this other classification we think about
David Hume think about Thomas Hobbes
perhaps a lot of other people who reduce
the virtues down to traits which lead us
to success Machiavelli could probably
fit in there as well he says that in
these sorts of cases
right we have the virtues as merely
means to the end of success or happiness
whatever it happens to be and the
relationship is external if you could
have the happiness or success without
having the virtues get rid of the
virtues they're not good in themselves
they're not a distinctive part of the
human Telos the point of human life you
might say so MacIntyre says we have
three very different conceptions of
virtue to confront and is it possible
for us to reconcile these and in any way
says are these three rival accounts of
the same thing or are they different
there they indeed accounts of three
different things and he's going to say
that they're they're ultimately going to
be measured within an Aristotelian
framework which he is supplying or we
might say a neo Aristotelian framework
but at this point it's enough for us to
note that these are three very different
conceptions of virtue so when somebody
uses the term virtue or talks about the
virtues or particular traits we want to
look to see what sort of viewpoint they
actually have on the nature and the
purpose of the virtues
you